old Masson the caretaker of one of
Salem's oldest and most neglected
cemeteries had a feud with the rats
generations ago they had come up from
the wharves and settled in the graveyard
a colony of abnormally large rats and
when Masson had taken charge after the
inexplicable disappearance of the former
caretaker he decided that they must go
at first she set traps for them and put
poison food by their burrows and later
he tried to shoot them but it did no
good
the rats stayed multiplying and over
running the graveyard with their
ravenous hordes they were large even for
the brown rat which sometimes measures
15 inches in length exclusive of the
naked pink and gray tail Masson had
caught glimpses of some as large as
good-sized cats and when once or twice
the gravediggers had uncovered their
burrows the malodorous tunnels were
large enough to enable a man to crawl
into them on his hands and knees the
ships that had come generations ago from
distant ports to the rotting Salem
wharves had brought strange cargoes
Masson wondered sometimes at the
extraordinary size of these burrows he
recalled certain vaguely disturbing
legends he had heard since coming to
ancient which haunted Salem tales of a
moribund inhuman life that was said to
exist and forgotten burrows in the earth
the old days when Cotton Mather had
hunted down the evil cults that
worshipped Hecate and the dark Magna
mater and frightful orgies had passed
but dark gabled houses still leaned
perilously toward each other over narrow
cobbled streets and blasphemous secrets
and mysteries were said to be hidden in
subterranean cellars and caverns where
forgotten pagan rites were still
celebrated in defiance of law insanity
wagging their grey heads wisely the
elders declared that there were worse
things than rats and maggots crawling in
the unhallowed earth of the ancient
Salem cemeteries
and then - there was this curious dread
of the rats Masson disliked and
respected the ferocious little rodents
for he knew the danger that lurked in
their flashing needle sharp fangs but he
could not understand the inexplicable
horror which the oldsters held for
deserted rat infested houses he had
heard vague rumors of ghoulish beings
that dwelt far underground and that had
the power of commanding the rats
marshalling them like horrible armies
the rats the old men whispered were
messengers between this world and the
grim and ancient caverns far below Salem
bodies had been stolen from graves for
nocturnal subterranean feasts they said
the myth of the Pied Piper is a fable
that hides a blasphemous horror and the
black pits of avarice have brought forth
hell spawn monstrosity 'he's that never
venture into the light of day Masson
paid little attention to these tales he
did not fraternize with his neighbors
and in fact did all he could to hide the
existence of the rats from intruders
investigation he realized would
undoubtedly mean the opening of many
graves and while some of the gnawed
empty coffins could be attributed to the
activities of the rats Masson might find
it difficult to explain the mutilated
bodies that lay in some of the coffins
the purest gold is used in filling teeth
and this gold is not removed when a man
is buried clothing of course is another
matter for usually the Undertaker
provides a plain broadcloth suit that is
cheap and easily recognizable the gold
is another matter and sometimes - there
were medical students and less reputable
doctors who were in need of cadavers and
not over scrupulous as to where these
were obtained so far Masson had
successfully managed to discourage
investigation he had fiercely denied the
existence of the rats even though they
sometimes robbed him of his prey Masson
did not care what happened to the bodies
after he had performed his gruesome
thefts but the rats inevitably dragged
away the whole cadaver through the hole
they not in the coffin the size of these
burrows occasionally worried meson then
- there was the curious circumstance of
the coffins always being not open at the
end never at the side or top it was
almost as though the rats were working
under the direction of some impossibly
intelligent leader now he stood in an
open grave and threw a last sprinkling
of wet earth on the heap beside the pit
it was raining a slow cold drizzle that
for weeks had been descending from soggy
black clouds the graveyard was a Slav of
yellow sucking mud from which the rain
washed tombstones stood up in irregular
battalions the rats had retreated to
their burrows and Masson had not seen
one for days but his gaunt unshaven face
was set in frowning lines the coffin on
which he was standing was a wooden one
the body had been buried several days
earlier but Masson had not dared to
disinterred before a relative of the
dead man had been coming to the grave at
intervals even in the drenching rain but
he would hardly come at this late hour
no matter how much grief he might be
suffering my son thought grinning wryly
he straightened and laid the shovel
aside from the hill on which the ancient
graveyard lay he could see the lights of
Salem flickering dimly through the
downpour
he drew a flashlight from his pocket he
would need light now taking up the Spade
he bent and examined the fastenings of
the coffin abruptly he stiffened
beneath his feet he sensed an unquiet
stirring and scratching and so something
were moving within the coffin for a
moment a pang of superstitious fear shot
through mass on and then rage replaced
it as he realized the significance of
the sound the rats had for stalled him
again
in a paroxysm of anger Masson wrenched
at the fastenings of the coffin he got
the sharp edge of the shovel under the
lid and pried it up until he could
finish the job with his hands then he
sent the flashlights cold beam darting
down into the coffin rain spattered
against the white satin lining the
coffin was empty Masson saw a flicker of
movement at the head of the case and
darted the light in that direction the
end of the sarcophagus had been gnawed
through and a gaping hole led into
darkness a black shoe limp and dragging
was disappearing as Masson watched and
abruptly he realized that the rats had
fur stalled him by only a few minutes he
fell on his hands and knees and made a
hasty clutch at the shoe and the
flashlight incontinently fell into the
coffin and went out the shoe was tugged
from his grasp he heard a sharp excited
squealing and then he had the flashlight
again and was darting its light into the
Burrow it was a large one it had to be
or the corpse could not have been
dragged along it Masson wondered at the
size of the rats that could carry away a
man's body but the thought of the loaded
revolver in his pocket fortified him
probably if the corpse had been an
ordinary one Masson would have left the
rats with their spoils rather than
venture into the narrow burrow but he
remembered an especially fine set of
cufflinks he had observed as well as a
stick pin that was undoubtedly a genuine
pearl with scarcely a pause he clipped
the flashlight to his belt and crept
into the Burrow it was a tight fit but
he managed to squeeze himself along
ahead of him in the flashlights glow he
could see the shoes dragging along the
wet earth on the bottom of the tunnel he
crept along the burrows as rapidly as he
could occasionally barely able to
squeeze his lean body through the narrow
walls
the air was overpowering with it's musty
stench of carrion if he could not reach
the corpse in a minute Masson decided he
would turn back
belated fears were beginning to crawl
maggot lake within his mind but greed
urged him on he crawled forward several
times passing the mouths of adjoining
tunnels the walls of the Burrow were
damp and slimy and twice lumps of dirt
dropped behind him the second time he
paused and screwed his head around to
look back he could see nothing of course
until he had unhooked the flashlight
from his belt and reversed it several
clods lay on the ground behind him and
the danger of his position suddenly
became real and terrifying with thoughts
of a cave in making his pulse race he
decided to abandon the pursuit even
though he had now almost overtaken the
corpse and the invisible things that
pulled it but he had overlooked one
thing the Burrow was too narrow to allow
him to turn panic touched him briefly
but he remembered a side tunnel he had
just passed and backed awkwardly along
the tunnel until he came to it he thrust
his legs into it backing until he found
himself able to turn then he hurriedly
began to retrace his way although his
knees were bruised and painful agonizing
pain shot through his leg he felt sharp
teeth sink into his flesh and kicked out
frantically there was a shrill squealing
and a scurry of many feet flashing the
light behind him Masson caught his
breath and a sob of fear as he saw a
dozen great rats watching him intently
their slitted eyes glittering in the
light they were great misshapen things
as large as cats and behind them he
caught a glimpse of a dark shape that
stirred and moved swiftly aside into the
shadow and he shuddered at the
unbelievable size of the thing the light
had held them for a moment but they were
edging closer their teeth dull orange in
the pale light Masson tugged at his
pistol managed to extricate it from his
pocket and aimed carefully it was an
awkward position and he tried to press
his feet into the soggy sides of the
Burrow
so that he should not inadvertently send
a bullet into one of them
the Rolling Thunder at the shot deafened
him for a time and the clouds of smoke
said him coughing when he could hear
again and the smoke had cleared he saw
that the rats were gone he put the
pistol back and began to creep swiftly
along the tunnel and then with a scurry
in a rush they were upon him again they
swarmed over his legs biting and
squealing insanely and Masson shrieked
horribly as he snatched for his gun he
fired without aiming and only luck saved
him from blowing a foot off this time
the rats did not retreat so far but
Masson was crawling as swiftly as he
could along the Burrow ready to fire
again at the first sound of another
attack there was a patter of feet and he
sent the light stabbing behind him a
great gray rat paused and watched him
its long ragged whiskers twitched and
its scabrous naked tail was moving
slowly from side to side masajid
and the rat retreated he crawled on
pausing briefly the black gap of a side
tunnel at his elbow as he made out a
shapeless huddle on the day at play a
few yards ahead for a second he thought
it was the mass of earth that had been
dislodged from the roof and then he
recognized it as a human body it was a
brown and shriveled mummy and with a
dreadful unbelieving shock Masson
realized that it was moving it was
crawling towards him and in the pale
glow of the flashlight the man saw a
frightful gargoyle face thrust into his
own
it was the passionless death's-head
skull of a long dead corpse instinct
with hellish life and the glazed eyes
swollen and bulbous betrayed the things
blindness it made a faint groaning sound
as it crawled toward Masson stretching
its ragged and granulated lips and a
grin of dreadful hunger and Masson was
frozen with abysmal fear and loathing
just before the horror touched him
Masson flung himself frantically into
the Burrow at his side he heard a
scrambling noise at his heels and the
thing groaned dully as it came after him
Masson glancing over his shoulder
screamed and propelled himself
desperately through the narrow burrow he
crawled along awkwardly sharp stones
cutting his hands and knees dirt
showered into his eyes but he dared not
pause even for a moment he scrambled on
gasping cursing and praying hysterically
squealing triumphantly the rats came at
him horrible hunger in their eyes Misano
must succumb to their vicious teeth
before he succeeded in beating them off
the passage was narrowing and in a
frenzy of terror he kicked and screamed
and fired until the hammer clicked on an
empty shell but he had driven them off
he found himself crawling under a great
stone embedded in the roof that dug
cruelly into his back it moved a little
as his weight struck it and an idea
flashed into massan's fright crazed mind
if he could bring down the stone so that
it blocked the tunnel the earth was wet
and soggy from the rains and he hunched
himself half upright and dug away at the
dirt around the stone the rats were
coming closer he saw their eyes glowing
in the reflection of the flashlights
beam still he clawed frantically at the
earth the stone was giving he tugged at
it and it rocked in its foundation a rat
was approaching the monster he had
already glimpsed gray and leprous and
hideous had crept forward with its
orange teeth bared and in its wake came
the blind dead thing groaning as it
crawled Masson gave a last frantic tug
at the stone he felt it slide downwards
and then he went scrambling along the
tunnel behind him the stone crashed down
and he heard a sudden frightful shriek
of agony clods showered upon his legs a
heavy weight fell on his feet and he
dragged them free with difficulty the
entire tunnel was collapsing gasping
with fear Masson threw himself forward
as the soggy earth collapsed at his
heels the tunnel narrowed until he could
barely use his hands and legs to propel
himself he wriggled forward like an eel
and suddenly felt satin tearing beneath
his clawing fingers
and then his head crashed against
something that barred his path he moved
his legs discovering that they were not
pinned under the collapsed earth he was
lying flat on his stomach and when he
tried to raise himself he found that the
roof was only a few inches from his back
panic shot through him when the blind
horror had blocked his path he had flung
himself desperately into a side tunnel a
tunnel that had no outlet he was in a
coffin an empty coffin into which he had
crept through the hole the rats had
gnawed in its end he tried to turn on
his back and found that he could not the
lid of the coffin pinned him down
inexorably then he braced himself and
strained at the coffin lid it was
immovable
and even if he could escape from the
sarcophagus how could he Klaus way up
through five feet of hard-packed earth
he found himself gasping it was
dreadfully fetid unbearably hot in a
paroxysms of Terror he ripped and clawed
at the satin until it was shredded he
made a futile attempt to dig with his
feet at the earth from the collapse
burrow that blocked his retreat if he
were only able to reverse his position
he might be able to claw his way through
the air air white-hot agony Lance
through his breast throbbed in his
eyeballs his head seemed to be swelling
growing larger and larger and suddenly
he heard the exultant squealing of the
rats he began to scream insanely but
could not drown them out for a moment he
thrashed about hysterically within his
narrow prison and then he was quiet
gasping for air his eyelids closed his
blackened tongue protruded and he sank
down into the blackness of death with a
mad squealing of the rats dinning in his
ears
in my tortured ears their sounds
unceasingly a nightmare whirring and
flapping and a faint distant baying as
if some gigantic hound it is not a dream
it is not I fear even madness for too
much has already happened to give me
these merciful doubts st. John is a
mangled corpse
I alone know why and such as my
knowledge that I am about to blow out my
brains for fear I shall be mangled in
the same way down unlit and illimitable
corridors of eldritch fantasy sweeps the
black shapeless nemesis that drives me
to self annihilation may heaven forgive
the folly and morbidity which led us
both to so monstrous of fate wearied
with the commonplaces of a prosaic world
where even the joys of romance and
adventure soon grow stale st. John and I
had followed enthusiastically every
aesthetic and intellectual movement
which promised respite from our
devastating ennui the enigmas of the
symbolist sand the ecstasy's of the pre
raphael eighths all were ours in their
time but each new mood was strained too
soon of its diverting novelty and appeal
only the sombre philosophy of the
decadence could help us and this we
found potent only by increasing
gradually the depth and diable ism of
our penetrations Baudelaire and Huysmans
were soon exhausted of thrills till
finally there remain for us only the
more direct stimuli of unnatural
personal experiences and adventures it
was this frightful emotional need which
led us eventually to that detestable
course which even in my present fear I
mentioned with shame and timidity that
hideous extremity of human outraged the
abhorred practice of grave robbing
I cannot reveal the details of our
shocking expedition or catalog even
partly the worst of the trophies
adorning the nameless Museum we jointly
dwelt alone and servantless our Museum
was a blasphemous unthinkable place
where with the Satanic tastes of
neurotic virtuosa we had assembled a
universe of terror and a secret room far
far underground were huge wing of demons
Carvin of basalt and onyx vomited from
wide grinning mouths weird green and
orange light and hidden pneumatic pipes
ruffled into kaleidoscopic dances of
death the line of red charnel things
handed hand-woven and voluminous black
hangings through these pipes came at
will the odors our moods most craved
sometimes the scent of pale funeral
lilies sometimes the narcotic incense of
imagined Eastern shrines of the kingly
dead and sometimes how I shudder to
recall it the frightful soul upheaving
stenches of the uncovered grave around
the walls of this repellent chamber were
cases of antique mummies alternating
with comely lifelike bodies perfectly
stuffed and cured by the taxidermist art
and with headstones snatched from the
oldest church yards of the world
Nisha's here and there contains skulls
of all shapes and heads preserved in
various stages of disillusion there one
might find the rotting bald pates of
famous noblemen and the flesh and
radiantly golden heads of new buried
children statues and paintings there
were all of fiendish subjects and some
executed by Saint John and myself a
locked portfolio bound and tanned human
skin held certain unknown and unnameable
drawings which it was rumored Goya had
perpetrated but dared not acknowledge
there were nauseous musical instruments
strings brass woodwind on which Saint
John and I sometimes produced distances
of exquisite morbidity and Kokoda
maniacal ghastliness whilst in a
multitude of inlaid ebony cabinets
reposed the most incredible and
unimaginable variety of tomb loot ever
assembled by human madness and
perversity it is of this loot in
particular that I must not speak thank
God I had the courage to destroy it long
before I thought of destroying myself
the predatory excursions on which we
collected our unmentionable treasures
were always artistically memorable
events we were no vulgar goals but
worked only under certain conditions of
mood landscape environment weather
season and moonlight these pastimes were
to us the most exquisite form of
aesthetic expression and we gave their
details of fastidious technical care an
inappropriate hour a jarring lighting
effect or a clumsy manipulation of the
damp sod would almost totally destroy
for us that ecstatic titillation which
followed the exhalation of some ominous
grinning secret of the earth our quest
for novel scenes and piquant conditions
was feverish and insatiate
st. John was always the leader and he it
was who led the way at last to that
mocking Ackerson spot which brought us
our hideous and inevitable doom by what
malign fatality were real óoer to that
terrible Holland churchyard I think it
was the dark rumour in legend during the
tales of one buried for five centuries
who had himself been a ghoul in his time
and it's stolen a potent thing from a
mighty Sepulcher I can recall the scene
in these final moments the pale autumnal
moon over the graves casting long
horrible shadows the grotesque trees
drooping sullenly to meet the neglected
grass and the crumbling slabs the vast
legions of strangely colossal bats that
flew against the moon the antique Ivy
Church pointing a huge spectral finger
at the livid sky the phosphorescent
insects that danced like death fires
under the use in a distant corner the
odors of mold vegetation and less
explicable things that mingled feebly
with the night wind from over far swamps
and seas and worst of all the faint
deep-toned baying of some gigantic hound
which we could neither see nor
definitely place as we heard this
suggestion of baying we shuddered
remembering the tales of the peasantry
for he whom we had sought had centuries
before been found in this self same spot
torn and mangled by the claws and teeth
of some unspeakable beast
I remember how we delved into the ghouls
grave with our spades and how we
thrilled at the picture of ourselves the
grave the pale watchin moon the horrible
shadows the grotesque trees the Titanic
bats
the antique church the dancing death
fires the sickening odors the gently
moaning night wind and the strange half
heard directionless baying
of whose objective existence we could
scarcely be sure
then we struck a substance harder than
the damp mould and beheld a rotting
oblong box crusted with mineral deposits
from the long undisturbed ground
it was incredibly tough and thick but so
old that we finally pried it open and
feasted our eyes on what it held much
amazingly much was left at the object
despite the lapse of 500 years the
skeleton though crushed in places by the
jaws of the thing that had killed it
held together with surprising firmness
and we gloated over the clean white
skull and its long firm teeths and its
eyeless sockets that had once glowed
with a charnel fever like our own in the
coffin lay an amulet of curious and
exotic design which had apparently been
worn around the sleepers neck
it was the oddly conventionalized figure
of a crouching winget hound or Sphinx
with a semi canine face and was
exquisitely carved an antique oriental
fashioned from a small piece of green
jade the expression of its features was
repellent in the extreme savoring at
once of death bestiality and malevolence
around the base was an inscription and
characters which neither Saint John nor
I could identify and on the bottom like
a maker seal was grave in a grotesque
and formidable skull
immediately upon beholding this amulet
we knew that we must possess it that
this treasure alone was our logical pail
from the century grave even had its
outlines been unfamiliar we would have
desired it but as we looked more closely
we saw that it was not wholly unfamiliar
alien it indeed was to all art and
literature which sane and balanced
readers know but we recognized it has
the thing hinted of in the forbidden
Necronomicon of the mad Arab Abdullah
has read the ghastly soul symbol of the
corpse eating cult of inaccessible
laying in Central Asia all too well did
we trace the sinister lineaments
described by the old arab demonologist
lineaments he wrote drawn from some
obscure supernatural manifestation of
the souls of those who vexed a nod at
the dead seizing the green jade object
we gave a last glance at the bleached
and cavern eyed face of its owner and
closed up the grave as we found it as we
hastened from the abhorrent spot the
stolen amulet and st. John's pocket we
thought we saw the bats descend in a
body to the earth we had so lately
rifled as if seeking for some cursed and
unholy nourishment but the autumn moon
shone weak and pale so we could not be
sure so too as we sailed the next day
away from Holland to our home we thought
we heard the faint distant baying of
some gigantic hound in the background
but the autumn wind moaned sad and won
and we could not be sure less than a
week after our return to England strange
things begin to happen we lived as wreck
losses devoid of friends alone and
without servants in a few rooms of an
ancient manor house on a bleak and
unfrequented more so that our doors were
seldom disturbed by the knock of the
visitor
now however we were troubled by what
seemed to be a frequent fumbling in the
night not only around the doors but
around the windows also upper as well as
lower once we fancied that a large
opaque body darkened the library window
when the moon was shining against it and
another time we thought we heard a
whirring or flapping sound not far off
on each occasion investigation revealed
nothing and we began to ascribe the
occurrences to imagination which still
prolonged in our ears the faint far
baying we thought we had heard in the
Holland churchyard the Jade amulet now
reposed an Anish in our Museum and
sometimes we burned a strangely scented
candle before it we read much in All
Hazards Necronomicon about its
properties and about the relation of
ghost souls to the objects that
symbolized and we were disturbed by what
we read then terror came on the night of
September 24th I heard a knock at my
chamber door fancying at Saint John's I
bade the knocker enter but was answered
only by a shrill laugh there was no one
in the corridor when I aroused Saint
John from his sleep he professed entire
ignorant of the event and became as
worried as I it was the night that the
faint distant baying over the moor
became to us a certain under netted
reality four days later while we were
both in the hidden Museum there came a
low cautious scratching at the single
door which led to the secret library
staircase our alarm was now divided for
besides our fear of the unknown we had
always entertained a dread that our
grisly collection might be discovered
extinguishing all lights we proceeded to
the door and through it suddenly open
whereupon we felt an unaccountable rush
of air and heard as if receding far away
a queer combination of rustling
tittering an articulate chatter whether
we were mad dreaming or in our senses we
did not try to determine we only
realized with the blackest of
apprehensions that the apparently
disembodied chatter was beyond a doubt
in the Dutch language
after that we lived in growing horror
and fascination mostly we held to the
theory that we were jointly going mad
from our life of unnatural excitements
but sometimes it pleased us more to
dramatize ourselves as the victims of
some creeping an appalling doom bizarre
manifestations were now to frequent to
count our lonely house was seemingly
alive with the presence of some malign
being whose nature we could not guess
and every night that demonic baying
rolled over the windswept more always
louder and louder on October 29th we
found in the soft earth underneath a
library window a series of footprints
utterly impossible to describe
they were as baffling as the hordes of
great bats which haunted the old manor
house in unprecedented and increasing
numbers the horror reached a culmination
on November 18th when st. John walking
home after dark from the dismal railway
station was seized by some frightful
carnivorous thing and torn to ribbons
his screams had reached the house and I
adhesive to the terrible scene in time
to hear a were of wings and see a vague
black cloudy thing silhouetted against
the rising moon my friend was dying when
I spoke to him and he could not answer
coherently all he could do was whisper
the amulet that damned thing then he
collapsed an inert mass of mangled flesh
I buried him the next midnight in one of
our neglected Gardens and mumbled over
his body one of the devilish rituals he
had loved in life and as I pronounced
the last demonic sentence
I heard afar on the moor the faint
baying of some gigantic hound the moon
was up but I dared not look at it and
when I saw on the dim lighted more a
wide nebulous shadow sweeping from mound
to mound I shut my eyes and threw myself
face down upon the ground when I arose
trembling I know not how much later I
staggered into the house and made
shocking obeisances before the enshrined
amulet of green jade
being now afraid to live alone in the
ancient house on the moor I departed on
the following day for London taking with
me the amulet after destroying by fire
and burial the rest of the Empire's
collection in the museum but after three
nights I heard the baying again and
before a week was over felt strange eyes
upon me whenever it was dark one evening
as I strolled on Victoria Embankment for
some needed air I saw a black shape
obscure one of the reflections of the
lamps in the water a wind stronger than
the night wind rushed by and I knew that
what had befallen st. John must soon
befall me the next day I carefully
wrapped the green jade amulet and sailed
for Holland what mercy I might gain by
returning the thing to its silent
sleeping owner I knew not but I felt
that I must try any step conceivably
logical what the hound was and why it
had pursued me were questions still
vague but I had first heard the baying
in that ancient churchyard and every
subsequent event including st. John's
dying whisper had served to connect the
curse with the stealing of the amulet
accordingly I sank into the nethermost
abyss of despair when at an inn in
Rotterdam I discovered that thieves had
to spoiled me of the sole means of
salvation the baying was loud that
evening and in the morning I read of a
nameless deed in the vilest quarter of
the city the rabble were in terror for
upon an evil tenement had fallen a red
death beyond the Fallas previous crime
of the neighbourhood in a squalid
thieves den an entire family had been
torn to shreds by an unknown thing which
left no trace and those around had heard
all night a faint deep insistent note as
effigy gantt account so at last I stood
again in the unwholesome churchyard
where a pale winter moon cast hideous
shadows and leafless trees drooped
sullenly to meet the withered frosty
grass and cracking slabs and the Ivy
Church pointed a jeering finger at the
unfriendly sky and the night wind howled
maniacally from over furs and swamps and
frigid seas the baying was very faint
now and it ceased altogether as I
approached the ancient grave I had once
violated and frightened away an
abnormally large horde of bats which had
been hovering curiously around it
I know not why I went thither unless to
pray or jibber out and sain please and
apologies to the calm white thing that
lay within but whatever my reason I
attacked the half frozen sod with a
desperation partly mine and partly that
of a dominating will outside myself
excavation was much easier than I had
expected though at one point I
encountered a queer interruption when a
lean vulture darted down out of the cold
sky and pecked frantically at the grave
earth until I killed him with a blow of
my Spade finally I reached the rotting
oblong box and removed a damped nitrous
cover this is the last rational act I
ever performed for crouched within that
century coffin embraced by a
close-packed nightmare retinue of huge
sinewy sleeping bats was the bony thing
my friend and I had robbed not clean and
Placid as we had seen it then but
covered with caked blood and shreds of
alien flesh and hair and leering
sentient lay at me with phosphorescent
sockets and sharp and sanguine fangs
yawning twisted Lea and mockery of my
inevitable doom and when it gave from
those grinning jaws a deep sardonic Bey
as if some gigantic hound and I saw that
it held in its gory filthy claw the lost
and fateful amulet of green jade I
merely screamed and ran away idiotic Lea
my scream soon dissolving into peals of
hysterical laughter madness rides the
star wind claws and teeth sharpened on
centuries of corpses dripping death
astride a bacchanal of bats from
kneidlach ruins of buried temples of
Belial now is the baying of that dead
fleshless monstrosity grows louder and
louder and the stealthy whirring and
flapping of those accursed web wings
circles closer and closer I shall seek
with my revolver the oblivion which is
my only refuge from the unnamed and the
unnameable
[Music]
when the estate of my uncle Alfred fry
is finally settled I shall give the farm
to George Harris I would not spend
another night in the house for all
creation but Harris is a strange
elemental sort of man he hated uncle
Alfred when he worked for him and now
that my uncle is gone he hates him still
I think it actually amuses him and as a
matter of fact I'm almost certain that I
heard him laugh aloud and shout pig in a
mocking falsetto on that last amazing
night that I spent at the farmhouse
there was the clatter of sharp hooves on
the bare floor of the hall and the
unmistakable grunting snuffle of a hog
the incongruous sound passed along the
corridor to the end where Harris's
cubbyhole of her room was I strode to my
door and flung it open and it was at
that moment that I heard Harris's roar
of mirth and the malicious Pig as if he
were calling the swine to dinner I
accused him of it later but he denied it
if that had been all I might have been
able to persuade myself that my
imagination was responsible but it was
not all not by any means
as a child I have a vague memory of a
tremendously fat man attending the
funeral for my mother and father this I
think must have been the first time that
I ever saw him but I'm sure that I did
not set eyes on him again for over 15
years although there is much of my
unhappy childhood that I have forgotten
Uncle Alfred's grotesque figure must
have stood out in my memory and all it's
terrifying bulk after all those years I
met uncle Alfred as a result of a rather
uncomfortable coincidence having left
the University with an excellently
engraved but otherwise worthless degree
I was at length fortunate enough to
obtain a job in New York City as a
process server in most cases to serve a
defendant with a summons requires little
more skill than that which might be
expected of an errand boy but it does
occasionally happen that considerable
ingenuity is necessary such a case was
that of uncle Alfred when my employer
gave me the summons for Alfred fry he
told me that he had been trying to serve
it for months and that he had exhausted
every dodge in his head try anything you
can think of he said I'm beginning to
believe the man doesn't exist I said if
he's the man I think he is the jobs as
good as done and I left the office with
a vision of my triumph in my mind it was
easy I would say on my return why there
was nothing to it at all
Alfred Frye lived in a big grey stone
house just off Fifth Avenue a townhouse
a residence the stately ugly dignified
sort of dwelling that millionaires
inhabit the front doors were plate glass
and wrought iron and as I ride the Bell
it occurred to me that it would be far
from safe to put my foot in the crack
when the door was opened presently a
Haggard sickly looking Butler asked me
my business is mr. Alfred Frye at home I
asked the butler believed that mr. Frye
was not at home I said if you should
happen to find him somewhere in there
would you tell him that his nephew
Julian Barrow would like to pay his
respects the butler stared at me
doubtfully and I repeated Julian Barrow
the butler said I'll see if mr. fry is
in and started to close the door before
the latch clicked I said tell him I
don't want to borrow any money he
disappeared into the interior darkness
without making any sign of having her
after what seemed a long time he
returned and said mr. fry will see you
I followed the butler through a long
gloomy hall that was draped and carpeted
in dark red and gold
there were several massive pieces of
carved furniture the sort of thing that
seems to have been made for the lobbies
of hotels whose guests are giants chairs
too large for one person but too small
for two tables too high for convenience
mirrors too large for comfort we came to
a broad oak door where the butler
stopped murmuring mr. fry is in the
study he swung it open and I went in
from behind his enormous desk my uncle
peered at me so he said in a high thin
voice you're Julian and you I said our
uncle Alfred I remember you and the odd
thing is that I did actually remember
him seeing him again I wondered how his
memory could ever have grown so dim it
was like seeing a motion picture or a
play for the second time inadvertently
though apparently you had forgotten
everything about it with the first
sequence the whole thing comes back in
complete detail I suppose he had changed
he must have changed in 15 years but it
seemed to me that I remembered him
exactly as I saw him now the man was a
hog that is the most accurate if not the
most charitable way to put it not having
seen him he may conclude that uncle
Alfred was merely a sufferer from some
such disease as dropsy er elephantiasis
but he was no invalid on the contrary he
appeared to be in the best of health and
spirits like a vigorous hog his head was
huge involved except for a few long
strands of straight black hair on the
crown the bulging jowls began just below
the rounded brow and descended a
sweeping curve that cradled the chin the
nose was short the tip raised in such a
way that it seemed to be lifting the
upper lip also the eyes were small
closely set and so deeply imbedded that
the lids were not visible they were keen
Restless eyes that darted from object to
object as if in hungry search for
something I caught myself wondering what
he was looking for a carrot an ear of
corn
well sit down he said sit down my boy
the last time I saw you you were a baby
and now look at you a grown man tell me
how you are what you're doing did you
know that you are my nearest living
relative his eyes made a quick search of
the room for nearer relatives it amused
me to think of the summons in my pocket
and of how angry my uncle would be when
I served in on him and it seemed to me
that the longer I delayed the greater
the joke so I sat down and answered his
questions volubly his curiosity about my
life somewhat surprised me for in the
past his interest and his help would
have been eagerly welcomed but he had
ignored my existence and it even failed
to reply to my Guardians letters uncle
Alfred was obviously impatient with the
account I gave him of my childhood he
grunted and twiddled his fat thumbs that
just managed to meet across his belly
and it was not until I mentioned my
fiancee that he seemed to prick up his
rather pointed ears ah he said you must
tell me about this girl her name a net
worth she is young of course beautiful
surely you love her very much why yes I
said certainly his sudden eagerness
annoyed me and some obscure way you're a
lucky boy a lucky boy he sighed
reflectively and when is the marriage to
be before I could draw breath he
answered his own question why that
depends on uncle Alfred that's why you
came here today will uncle Alfred give
his loving nephew enough money so that
he can be married I was angry but at the
same time delighted how can he have
stepped into the trap more effectively I
got to my feet and smiled down at his
obese head
why no My dear uncle I said my reason
for coming here was nothing of the sort
it was simply a matter of business I
reached into my pocket and drew out the
paper I have here a summons for one
Alfred Frye it gives me pleasure to
serve it on you and I slapped it down on
the desk in front of him he snatched it
up in his puffy hands and let out a
squeal of rage that was exactly like the
sound of a pig caught under a gate I
laughed at him and started toward the
door wait he called after me wait Julian
I turned and was amazed to see that his
face was creased and folded into a kind
of porcine smile don't go come back and
sit down this he picked up the summons
and flung it aside doesn't mean anything
I should have had to settle the case
eventually anyhow I'm sorry for what I
said now be a good boy come back and
let's be friends I had nothing to lose
and although I did not like my uncle his
remarkable change of manner excited my
curiosity and impelled me to accept his
invitation it was as simple a thing as
returning to my chairs it altered the
whole probable course of my life
my uncle sang attuned to the title blood
is thicker than water
it was a sweet subtle melody and well
calculated to fall pleasantly on my ears
I was broke and I was in love
uncle Alfred was rich and lonely and
after all I was his nearest blood
relative the logical person to inherit
his fortune with a hint of tears in his
shoe button eyes he described to me the
misunderstanding and ridicule that it
cursed his life he had no friends a
woman's love he had never known even his
own relations among them his brother my
father had refused him their sympathies
in short it was a melancholy recital
late in the afternoon he began to plead
with me to invite a net to his house and
nothing would do but that we would stay
for dinner
from the moment of Annette's arrival
uncle Alfred's manner changed again he
stopped his moaning and became on the
instant a picture pathetic and almost
absurd gallantry in every way possible
he showed a net that she was welcome
that she was much more than welcome as
the evening wore on he became more and
more outspoken in his praises both for a
net and for me we were his beloved
long-lost niece and nephew the darlings
of his old age sent by Providence to
comfort his final years in leaving him
the last thing that he said to us was
remember children I have great plans for
you great plans for us all
when we were out on the street and the
door closed behind us
I asked Annette well what do you think
of him the poor old man she said it's
not his fault he's so fat perhaps not
entirely I said but to judge by the way
he acted at dinner he had something to
do with it
you mustn't be too critical he seems
awfully fond of you yes I said as much
to myself as to her and I would very
much like to know why I was a long time
finding the answer if I ever did
we saw uncle Alfred frequently in the
days that followed I do not recall
exactly how he first introduced the
subject of his farm but each time we
visited him he talked more and more
enthusiastically of it strictly as a
farm it was nothing he told us only a
few acres in the hills upstate an old
house dating from revolutionary times
that had been restored and modernized
a small orchard a plot or two of
vegetables but the pigs that was the
attraction for him he boasted that he
had six of the finest pens of pedigreed
hogs in the country and when he spoke of
them it was with the same admiration and
affection that a hunter lavishes upon
his dog shortly after our first meeting
uncle Alfred insisted that Annette and I
spent a weekend with him at the
farmhouse we found the place much as he
had described it a rather charming old
building sent among ancient fruit trees
and a little distance there was a modern
barn which was flanked by a series of
elaborately constructed pig pens I had
always thought of pigs as wallowing in
mud and refuse but these pens were as
clean and dry as the cage of any animal
in the zoo each enclosure contained four
well-groomed hogs George Harris lived on
the property and acted as a caretaker he
was a lanky leather skinned farmer surly
in manner taciturn and completely
without humor of any civilized variety
from the beginning however I was
conscious of a bond of sympathy between
Harris and me unspoken and unadmitted I
believe it was nonetheless real
a net was more charitable than I she
loved the house
the pigs did not disgust her and she was
even able to persuade herself that uncle
Alfred's almost insane fondness for them
was somehow praiseworthy even when he
would get into the pen with them scratch
their bristly backs with a stick call
them individually by name and grunt
crooning Liat them a net felt only a
kind of sorrow for the loveless life
that had brought my uncle at last two
pigs on that first evening at my uncle's
house in New York he had said remember
children I have great plans for you but
I doubt very much if he spoke the truth
instead I think he realized that
eventually he would have a plan when he
had had time to devise one of sufficient
intricacy when the scheme finally
emerged it was so delicately constructed
so beautifully balanced that I
completely failed to recognize it one
night my uncle said Julian my boy I
don't know if I ever told you that I
have several important business
interests in South America as you can
see I'm not built for travelling so I've
always employed agents to represent me
but agents are not always entirely
trustworthy now if only you could speak
Spanish the offer expanded slowly and
alluringly
like dawn that begins with a line of
light on the horizon and gradually sets
the whole sky ablaze first I would give
up my miserable job and devote my entire
time for a period of three or four weeks
to the study of the South American
enterprises and to learning enough
Spanish to handle my uncle's affairs
then Annette and I could be married and
sail to Rio for our honeymoon the salary
would be large but even this was not all
in addition uncle Alfred proposed to
make me his sole heir there was one
other detail uncle Alfred insisted that
a net give up her work in the room where
she lived
he wished her to stay at the Savoy Plaza
and his expense laughing he said that
she must begin to accustom herself to
life as the wife of a rich man
the month of preparation went according
to my uncle's schedule a net spent most
of her time shopping for her trousseau
and my days were filled by my studies on
the date set for our marriage we three
went to the farm where it was my uncle's
whim to have the ceremony performed we
would spend the night there and sail in
the morning for Brazil all the
arrangements were in uncle Alfred's
hands hiring the minister buying the
tickets and so on apparently he enjoyed
playing Lord bountiful for his face was
like a smiling mold of jelly when we
arrived at the farm the weather was
unnaturally warm and threatening heavy
sluggish clouds hung low in the sky the
air was oppressive Lee still and it
seemed to me that I could feel the
vibration of distant thunder though it
was not yet audible even the Hogs seemed
affected by the sultry atmosphere they
were restless and irritable and kept up
an annoying squeal of complaint Uncle
Alfred's gaiety was somewhat dampened by
the discovery that George Harris was
absent without leave he said that he
suppose Harris would show up in time to
feed the pigs but meanwhile he strongly
disapproved of the man leaving the farm
alone even for a short while suppose
something should happen to one of the
Hogs with nobody here to help Annette
and I were in a state of comatose bliss
our new life lay before us but had not
yet quite begun with my arm around her I
remember wandering around the house and
grounds seeing little thinking of
nothing but the future the future that
we owed entirely to the kindness of my
uncle
the minister was expected at two o'clock
at 3:00 he had not arrived and since the
sky was growing more and more ominous I
began to fear that if he did not come
soon a storm might interfere with making
the trip that day uncle Alfred said that
he would telephone to find out the
reason for the delay he waddled out of
the living room and down the hall to his
own bedroom where the telephone was as I
heard his door closed I heard also the
first deep growl of thunder the passage
of time meant nothing to Annette and me
but I suppose it must have been more
than half an hour later when uncle
Alfred appeared in the doorway and
clapped his pink hand to his forehead in
a gesture of despair my god Julian he
groaned the most terrible thing has
happened I don't know how to tell you I
can't tell you we stared at him what is
it I demanded the minister no not that I
tried to reach him and there was no
answer so I suppose he's on his way if
it were only that then what afterwards
you see I called my office I won't stop
to tell you all about it now but he
sighed deeply Julian my boy you must fly
to Mexico City at once my office has
made a reservation for you on the
earliest plane we must leave here within
an hour as I started to protest he
handed me along envelope that was sealed
in a number of places with red wax here
take this I'll tell you about it before
you go Oh Julian I'm so sorry about this
so sorry then he sighed again and added
but Journeys End in lovers meeting you
know a net will follow you as soon as
your mission is finished I interrupted
why shouldn't she come with me now ah he
said there was another piece of bad luck
terrible luck there was only room for
one more passenger on the plane but
don't worry I'll send her to you at the
first possible moment he put his arm as
far as it would go around her waist and
murmured poor poor girl a net looked at
me with shining eyes it's all right it's
your job I can understand that
I'll follow you darling of course she
will uncle Alfred assured me and if
there isn't time for you to be married
here she'll marry you wherever you are
won't you my dear
I was enraged by something indefinable
in my uncle's manner or perhaps it was
by the situation itself in any case I
remembered the insane each to sink my
fingers into my uncle's fat neck to
squeeze the life from his disgusting
body but I stood silent in the gloomy
room as if waiting for the next thing to
happen a net released herself came to me
and put her hands on my shoulders
raising her head she whispered think of
the future darling will be so happy for
so long I kissed her and my anger was
gone the Thunder had grown louder and
suddenly there was a piercing squeal
from one of the hogs as if it were being
injured my uncle trundled out of the
room calling back come along Julian I'll
tell you what you must know while I see
what's the matter I held in at a moment
longer before I followed the sky was
boiling black with intermittent flashes
of lightning on the horizon but so far
there was little wind and no rain the
pens were over a hundred yards from the
house and not visible from it owing to
the curb of the hill as I started along
the path I heard steps behind me and
turned to see George Harris coming
around the corner of the porch looks
like bad weather I said where have you
been my uncle's been looking for you has
he why anything missing missing I
repeated I'll ask him myself we walked a
few paces side-by-side I only came back
for a saw I forgot we had topped the
hill and we're looking down at Uncle
Alfred who was bending over one of the
hogs in the third pen before Harris's
statement struck me as curious I halted
and said what do you mean has something
happened between you and mr. fry why
sure didn't you know I'm fired he called
me up yesterday and told me to be off
the place by this morning distant
lightning glinted in Harris's sardonic
eyes as I gazed at him wonderingly wide
uncle Alfred pretended to think that
Harris would return the answer was in
the closed cell of my brain I knew it
was there but I could not find it that's
strange I said at last and we went down
the hill to the pen inside of which my
uncle was comforting one of his swine
without looking up my uncle said Galahad
has scratched himself on a nail or
something of the sort awful thing to
happen at a moment like this just when
I've got to give you your instructions
and send you
off Harris cut in did you want to see me
my uncle was obviously startled he
jerked his head around and exclaimed
what Oh Harris no I don't want to see
you why would I I spoke to you yesterday
and I haven't changed my mind
Harris nodded and leaned against the
wall of the pen my uncle stood up sweat
was glistening on his forehead and gels
his upper lip was raised over his yellow
teeth and he looked less human than
usual well he cried get on about your
business I've got to talk to my nephew
sure said Harris I just wondered if you
knew the telephone lines been cut I
noticed it when I came around the house
just now damn you
my uncle shouted go on I won't listen to
your nonsense he turned to me
Julian you must hurry go before the
storm breaks you'll find the man at the
address on the letter oh why are you
there at that moment the Hogg named
Galahad broke away and trotted painfully
to the far end of the pen my uncle
trotted after him and then a wide
blinding river of fire spilled out of
the sky I heard it sizzle and crackle
before the Thunder came and before the
Thunder had echoed away I smelled the
sulphur strong and still air I turned to
Harris and said shakily that was close
Harris was staring into the pen a look
of amazement on his face as my gaze
followed his I too was amazed
my uncle had disappeared I said did you
see him go how did he get away so
quickly suddenly the rain began to fall
as if were a dashed out of buckets but
Harris remained a few seconds leaning
over the wall of the pen five i heard
him mutter yes by god five i waited no
longer but ran back to the house where I
arrived soaked and breathless a net met
me at the door pale and frightened
wasn't the lightning ghastly where's
uncle Alfred isn't he here and then it
occurred to me where he must have gone
oh I said he's in the barn of course
though how he got away so quickly I
can't imagine Harris came striding out
of the rain and joined us on the porch
I noticed he was carrying the handsaw he
had mentioned and I asked did you go to
the barn yes
was mr. Frye there
he looked at me and what I thought was a
very curious way but he made no answer
and I asked the question again did you
see mr. fry when you got your saw out of
the barn a strange almost mocking smile
spread over Harris's angular face slowly
he dropped the lid over one eye in an
Adagio wink and at last he uttered the
one syllable no and where is he
if you don't know said Harris I don't
know a net said you both better come in
and dry your clothes
anyhow darling you can't possibly get to
the airport in this weather no these
clay roads will be impassable for at
least several hours I suppose I had
better phone Uncle Alfred's office to
have them cancel the plane reservation
but I wish he'd come back here I don't
really know what to do Harris chuckled
deep in his chest and then I remembered
what he had said about the telephone I
told him that he must be mistaken about
it because uncle Alfred was making a
call just a few minutes before Harris
said try it if you want to as I started
out of the room he asked did you notice
how many hogs there was in that pen we
was leaning over four I said there were
four in each of the pens you know that
better than I there's five in that pen
now Harris told me and next time you go
down I'll ask you to look close at one
hog in particular he's the biggest and
the fattest and he's got no ring in his
nose apparently this meant much more to
Harris than to me to me the explanation
seemed obvious simply that uncle Alfred
had bought a new hog during Harris's
absence I did not begin to take the man
seriously until I raised the telephone
receiver to my ear the line was dead
the discovery of the severed telephone
was the first link in a chain of
astonishing revelations as soon as the
condition of the road permitted Annette
Harris and I drove down to the village
of oak tree through the drugstore
telephone I began to learn some of the
truths about my missing uncle uncle
Alfred had never spoken to the minister
whom he had been expecting I called the
north south continental company which
was uncle Alfred's New York headquarters
they had never heard of an Alfred Frye I
called the airport and found somewhat to
my surprise that there was a reservation
in my name in canceling it I asked when
the ticket had been bought and whether
there was more room on the plane there
was more room and the passage had been
reserved three days in advance while I
still sat in the telephone booth Annette
and Harris waiting outside I tore open
the elaborately sealed envelope uncle
Alfred had given me it was addressed to
Carlos Diaz Hotel Geneva Mexico City and
it contained two sheets a perfectly
blank paper for the moment the problem
was too much for me I went out and told
Harris to notify the local authorities
of uncle Alfred's disappearance and then
go back to the house and stay there
until he heard from us or we heard from
him he looked at me I wish Lee what
should I do about the Hogs damn the Hogs
I exclaimed what difference does it make
to me do anything even the the new one
of course if I thought anything I
suppose I thought the man was talking
about feeding the brutes a net Niger of
back to New York and went directly to
uncle Alfred's town house the place was
closed shades drawn at all the windows
the front door locked there we were the
mystery seemed as complete as our
despair
but within the next few days our
fortunes took a sudden upward turn I got
a much better position that I could have
hoped for and within a short time
Annette and I were married so far as I
know Alfred Frye was never seen again
although it seems impossible that such a
tremendously fat man could vanish like
an illusion and a distorting mirror a
search has been made for him throughout
the world in vain if he does not turn up
in the time specified by law his death
will be legally presumed and his
considerable estate which does not
include ownership in the north-south
continental company will come to me it
seems I am his sole living relative I
hesitate to speak of the night Annette
and I spent at the farmhouse because as
a reasonable unimaginative man I'm not
willing to argue the accuracy of my own
impressions we went up to the country
shortly after our marriage and within a
month of my uncle's disappearance the
first thing I noticed was that the pins
were completely empty and I asked Harris
what had happened to the hogs oh he said
I sent them to market you'll be getting
a check for them I said if my uncle ever
shows up he'll throw you in jail for it
Harris grinned at me if he ever shows up
after dinner Annette Harris and I talked
once again about the mystery of uncle
Alfred there was little doubt in my mind
of what the old devil had planned and I
was certain that if I had made the trip
to Mexico I should never have returned
as I said whatever happened to him and
however it happened it seemed to me that
only the merest eleventh-hour luck had
saved my life and spared Annette the
most terrible fate Harris said nothing
but sat staring into the firelight the
sound woke me from a deep sleep in the
middle of the night the clatter of
hooves on the hardwood floor in the hall
outside our door I waited listening
while the Beast stopped and snuffled
along the bottom of the door as if food
were just beyond his reach
then the clatter began again as the hog
started down the hall I jumped out of
bed and was in the long straight
corridor before the trotting hooves had
reached the end there was nothing to see
as I stared into empty space
I heard Harris called Pig and it seemed
to me that the sound of the sharp hooves
on the bear
fluor appeared to enter Harris's room
but the door on either open or closed
fortunately the commotion had not
awakened Annette and I did not wish to
frighten her now i sat up for the rest
of the night thinking I shall not say
what I thought nor shall I advance any
theories but when the estate of my uncle
Alfred Frye is settled
Harris shall have the farm